ومعنا حول اخر المستجدات هناك من مدينه
ادروج كيف كان منفذته
مرحبا بك كنت اليوم في بخمول حيث تحتضم
المعارك كيف يبدو الوضع في المدينه
في الحقيقه مجرده دخول الى المدينه يمشي
بدايه بعنف المعارك هناك معارك باغلبها
مدفعيه وعبر الرشاشات الثقيله كل
الزجاج في المباني محطم بالكامل اكثر من
90% من سكان بخمود تركوها من بقي هناك هم
كبار السن هناك طبعا وجود الجيش الاوكراني
في القسم الغربي من المدينه من الواضح جدا
لان نهر الذي يقطع هذه المدينه الى جوزين
باتحدا فاصلا بين الجزء الغربي والجزء
الشرقي هذا الجزء الشرقي الذي بات يسميها
كثيرون المنطقه الرماديه هناك ايضا وجود
القوات الاوكرانيه واثناء وجودنا كان
واضحا حجما تبادل المدفعيه بين الجانبين
لنلقي نظره على اييي بعض او مشهد من ما
خبرناها اثناء محاولاتنا الخروج من
المدينه
ميساء قسمه قليل من المدنيين بقوه هناك
رغم المعارك العنيفه تحدثت الى البعض منهم
ما هي مشاهداتك عن يومياتهم
اكيد انه في ظل الماء اشاهدناها وهذه صوره
التي رايناها مع زميل رجيم من الواضح ان
من بقي وهم كبار العمر نعلم ان الغاز
مقطوع في المدينه الكهرباء مقطوعه كبار
العمر احيانا نباتوا شبه معزولين هناك
احيانا صعوبه
بايجاد الطعام بالنسبه الى قسم منهم
التقيتوا بمتطوعين همم قاموا بترتيب
وتنظيم ما يشبهها النقاط الخاصه التي يمكن
فيها لمن يريد المجيء اولا لي التدفئه لان
الوسيله الوحيده اللي تدفئه هي عبر مواقف
الحطب ايضا الكهرباء مقطوعه وبالتالي هناك
من ياتي فقط يشحن الهواتف يتكلم ليتمكن من
ان يطمئن الاحباء او اللي يطمئن على من هم
في قسم اخر من المدينه ايضا هناك توزيع
الادويه ولو ان الامر لا كافي يعني همم
دائما كان ملفتا بالنسبه الي الحديث
تحديدا مع كبار العمر الذين يقولون انه
رغم كل شيء لم يكن لديهم اي خيار اخر اما
الخوف فهو عنصر واضح همم الكل تحديدا من
كبار العمر يتذكرون
حقبه سابقه البعض يقول نعم نخاف لكن لا
نستطيع ان نفعل الكثير علما ان عمليات
الاجلاء لا تزال مستمره من هذه المدينه
ولو بوتيره اخف وتخضع للمعطيات الامنيه
للحظات او الساعات التي تكون فيها
المعارك المدفعيه اكثر هدوءا في المدينه
شكرا لك مايسه عواد كنت معنا مباشره من
الميدان في اوكرانيا